This review is tweeted
to us by @JustinMFR.
- Aha.
- He writes...
I guess, uh, I guess
I'm off to seek glory.
- In a hole.
- Yes.
Good. Okay.
♪
(Forrest)
There are two types of holes
in the world,
those that promise glory
and those that do not.
♪
And though I'd never considered
the question before,
it was no simple task to
distinguish one from the other.
Excuse me,
is this a glory hole?
That's a family hole.
♪
Do you know if there's anything
on the Internet
about where to find
anonymous sex?
I think pretty much
the whole Internet is for that.
That has not been my experience
with the Internet,
but I'm looking
for a glory hole, in particular.
Oh, if you're looking
for a glory hole,
you should just go to, like,
a seedy gay bar.
[chuckles]
Okay.
That is quite possibly
the least helpful suggestion
you could ever have made.
[chuckles]
I mean, why would a woman give
anonymous oral sex at a gay bar?
[chuckles]
I'll look online.
(Forrest)
Josh and the Internet
came through,
locating a long list of
active glory holes in my area.
There were a lot
of lonely ladies
and a lot of glory holes
in this city.
I headed to the one closest
to my dad's house.